good afternoon everybody and welcome to
part two of today's plans committee
meetings
and welcome to those who
joining us on youtube on the tour
youtube channel
our first application continuing our
agenda
is on page 68 to 79 degree agenda
and helen leave room to present
[Music]
uh
[Music]
what's moving
um
so this application reference one zero
five zero nine twenty twenty one rem
and it's a reserve matters
it's all reserved matters so you've got
access you've got appearance landscaping
layout and scale it is pursuant to
outline permission
one forward slash zero seven zero two
of 2017 pro ut
for a car park there's about 50 50 space
car park an associated access
landscaping and ancillary infrastructure
the application has been called in by
council brown for plans committees to
assess amenity and overlooking
just before i run through the
presentation um
i have just
a verbal update on two representations
that have been received since the report
was published
the first one
doesn't doesn't raise anything new but
beyond what is already set out in your
summary of representations
but for comprehensiveness and it
suggests there's no need for the car
park referencing
the
current
school streets initiative
um greatest concern over lots of trees
and hedgerow
privacy concerns and concerns over
anti-social behavior as well
there's been a second email that has
been circulated
and i'm aware that this has gone to all
members of the committee so you're
obviously aware of
a representation that has come in
so i won't
go through the detail of that
um there are a couple points of
clarification there will be merit and
we're just addressing now um
the second representation um suggests
that the
there's no reference to the car park in
the appeal decision so this is
referencing 181 houses that were allowed
last year by an appeal inspector um
just to refer you to page 75 of your
agenda report specifically the third
paragraph there is reference made to
um the outline commission being
being
referenced within the section 106 that's
associated with that appeal decision
and it does require a car park and it
references this application site
or it allows for an alternative car park
to come forward so um
that there is there is a clear reference
with that appeal decision just just to
clarify that um which indicates that the
appeal inspector did accept the car park
as suitable mitigation in highways terms
and the only other point i just wanted
to provide clarification on in terms of
the
correspondence that's been circulated um
it's suggested that the outlying clue is
highlighted at the outline expired on
the 28th of june of this year um
that that's correct in so far as
um
permission was granted
june 2018 however the conditions on the
outline
either require development within three
years so by the 28th of june or the
submission of a reserve matters
application and we did receive the
reserve matters application in may so
just just to give members assurance that
it is still a valid ongoing
[Music]
and
okay so moving on to the first
first drawing this is the site location
plan
um the application site covers an area
of approximately 0.4 hex heads
just looking at this plant you can see
that the although it's not fully shown
on here tyler's meadow
a residential scheme of 14 dwellings is
immediately to the north beyond that you
have blue coats primary school which is
approximately 150 metres to the north
and caddywell lane's the main access
road
road coming down and the reserve matters
the extent of the matters does
correspond precisely with the outline
red line
this this shows an aerial photo the site
is outlined in red you can see it's a
the southeast side of great towington um
it's approximately 600 meters to the
town centre from from the application
site
it's just zooming in on the site as you
can see it's currently agricultural land
forms part of a larger
parcel a field castle and there is a
gate access that comes out directly
opposite tyler's meadow which is a
typical agricultural field gate and the
the site the wider field is surrounded
by
pedro
and the rest is open open to the rest of
the field
this is the extract from
the great tarrington proposals map and
the north general torch local plan
as you can see the site which is against
outlined in red it sits outside with
adjacent to the development boundary
therefore it's technically open
countryside um you'll also see there's
no
landscape or heritage designations and
the site is within 201
this is the indicative plan that
plans committee would have considered
back in
2018 for
for the car park
outline stage and
[Music]
helpful to have regard to that in terms
of
what
in terms of establishing that principle
of the car park what was indicatively
shown and as you'll see further on um
it's essentially consistent now the
layout that's being brought forward
also for the
setting the wider context this is the
access
plan that was approved by the appeal
inspector in relation to 381 dwellings
at burwood
specifically in the bottom left-hand
corner you can see the access
arrangements that have been approved in
detail by the inspector which
correspond to the application site and
as you can see there is a main point of
access that comes across the top bit of
the site providing access to tyler's
meadow
and
and then the application scientist sits
below that
and this again for reference and context
is the indicative plan for the burwood
housing development
this is not approved in detail it is
just access that was approved in detail
however it
hopefully gives members an understanding
of how
the
surrounding immediate immediately
surrounding area is likely to be
developed should that site come forward
so to the east and to the south where we
would be housing
now just running through some photos
this is a view up kelly well lane slices
to the south
and the school is a short distance
further up on the left
and this is looking the other way
looking towards the application site
where the new
works to kelly wallace and the
improvements to kelly while they would
result in the highway extending straight
through and cutting through the hedge
that you can see in front of you
this is the relationship with the site
with thailand's meadow we've got 13 and
14 and there was one and two
tyler's meadow the name that separates
them from the application site in the
hedgerow that is the boundary to the
site from the left
slightly closer relationship with number
one numbers one and two tyler's meadow
and
the the level of the lane
relative
to to the houses
and again just looking from the westerly
direction now and you can see numbers 14
and 15 tyler's meadow um there was a
question asked about the
level the change in height between the
main and the top of the hedge bank and i
can confirm that's approximately two and
a half meters so from the road
to laying up to the the top bit of the
hedge fund that doesn't allow for the
planting on top of the hedge fund so you
can get a two and a half meter
level difference roughly
and a cloak closer view of um numbers
one and two tyler's meadow
now just a few photos from within the
site itself this is standing within the
site looking towards tyler's meadow you
can see the existing field gate there
again this is trying to show that
existing hedge boundary
[Music]
noting the gradients and the site just
slope slightly towards the south
again just to
show the nature of that hedge bank so
what you can see it doesn't start
terribly clearly
the top of the hedge bank is almost
level with that raised bit of grass in
the field that is proposed for this for
it to be leveled so that that part that
you can see this is level with the top
of the hedge bank not the planting above
it
and just get just a further view for
context
just panning around so the new access
road that's being approved will enter
the site
just immediately to the right of the
stone building so we've got the solar
panels and then the tile roof and stone
building the axis would come in to the
site at that point
this is kellywell meadow which is on the
other side of
the lane to the east
now just looking from the field gate
there's just a few photos that pan
around the site
and just moving on to what is proposed
so this is the proposed layout plan
and
as shown earlier it is broadly
consistent with the layout put forward
outline stage to establish the principle
it does propose or provide 50 spaces in
terms of scale and amount there is an in
and out point of access
um as you can see and then the access
that's already approved through the
appeal decision immediately to the north
which serves tyler's meadow
and there are also access works
to carry lane proposed
so it involves a widening of the
carriageway and
roughly two meter footwear on either
side and the carriage is varies between
sort of 5.5 to 6 and then there is a
slight cut in i'm sure if you have any
questions on that for her
to clarify
um
the
proximity to tyler's the properties in
tyler's meadows numbers one two 14
13. um it ranges from sort of 20 meters
from the closest lengths of the site
although it needs to be appreciated the
orientation of those parking spaces um
certainly with numbers one and two they
don't necessarily directly look at those
properties there have been
representations raising concern over
amenities specifically
the levels and
chance for overlooking and
light shining into the bedroom windows
so as as shown on the virtual side visit
there are
there is a bedroom window in each of
those upper floors
but there is a distance of at least sort
of 20 meters between
between those those properties and as
you can see from the section
um
the
the distance from
[Music]
[Applause]
is about two
two and a half meters up to the top of
the bank then you've got the hedge
funding above
the tree that you can see that shows the
planting that's proposed 13 trees are
proposed to be planted along that hedge
boundary as well within a fence on the
other side and then the car park
um would be would be cited within that
following section such as the field for
um how that relates to those bedroom
windows
that there is a distance of at least
sort of 20 meters and actually when the
weather levels are slightly higher and
away from the planting that distance
extends to at least 35 meters in the
middle of the application site
and
and there is landscaping is for
consideration there is a separate
condition on the outline which requires
details of timing
and plant specifications so as you can
see
the purple
tree symbols that relates to fruit trees
which will be planted all along that
sort of north western boundary the
majority of that hedge on the western
side is to be retained um
there is a point apart that would be
lost where the new access comes through
um
there's some blue shaded areas of
wildflower meadows there's additional
hedge and tree planting on all the
southern boundary as well
um
it does give rise to a biodiversity net
gain and a lot of the landscaping is
consistent with the requirements of the
ecology
assessment that was conditioned that
outlined stage
um a question was raised at the virtual
sciences over drainage um as you're
aware and i set out in the committee
report drainage matters are to be done
by a condition that's been applied on
the outline surprise commencement
details of the drainage strategy
have to be approved
and
the condition also specifically refers
back to the flood risk assessment that
was considered as part of the outline so
back in 2018 committee members would
have been aware of that flood risk
assessment and it's specifically
referenced that just to provide some
additional information
and so the drainage strategy
comprises three key elements so one
being the soak away that you can see
highlighted in blue
now there is an additional access road
that is coming through in the vicinity
of that soak away however
there is an area of green space just to
the north
of the top section that would be
retained
so it is expected that the soak away
could be accommodated within that
retained area of open space the second
element is that the car park itself
is surfaced with permeable gravel and
that is what is proposed
and also a french drain is to extend
around the outside edge as you can see
highlighted there of the car park as
well so the flood risk
assessment which formed past the outline
confirmed that these measures in
combination would be acceptable and
actually that the permeable gravel and
the french drain
actually exceeded the requirements it
was almost over designed for what the
likely surface water
flow would be post development
so just just finishing now summarizing
the main planning considerations
so the principle of development is
accepted there is an outline planning
permission in place
and the that outline permission is
specifically referenced in the third
section 106
and it is
required through a trigger um within
that legal agreement
in regards to access
um the whole officer did initially raise
objection and this was primarily
primarily due to concerns that the
proposal put forward did not was not
consistent and did not correspond with
the access arrangements that have been
approved as part of the therwood appeal
and consequently
further amended drawings were received
along with the road safety audit um the
proposal is now more than consistent
with what has already been approved um
through the appeal
and there are no highway objections
in terms of layout scale and external
appearance
the carpet provides for 50 spaces which
is consistent with the outline and the
expectation in terms of the need to
mitigate the housing development no
structures are proposed
it is likely that some sort of gate and
barrier would come forward at the two
points of entrance and exit however they
are to be considered by a condition on
the outline along with their
maintenance and management strategy
including hours of operation the section
106 also requires a management scheme a
confirmation of and it confirms that
either um it would be transferred to the
school if not then a management company
would take it on to the owner would be
responsible for setting that up but a
scheme has to be approved
and
in terms of landscaping
there are a number of elements proposed
there are trees hedges wildflower
meadows
and these are
consistent with ecology report as well
so there is a net gain consequently
being being secured
drainage um i touched on that a moment
ago
that the exact detail of that would be
secured by a condition prior to
commencement however what is before you
for consideration is consistent with the
flight risk assessment that it requires
that the condition requires that
strategy to be in accordance with
and
and yeah as i said ecology and net gain
is being delivered and it is compliant
with the ecology assessment that was
conditioned through the outline and some
concerns have been raised over external
lighting both in terms of visual impact
humanity impact and leicester ecology
the ecology appraisal that's conditioned
does require to specify a type of
lighting to a very low level
type of lighting for to protect
ecological interests
in any event
details have to be submitted and
approved by the local planning authority
in due course so there aren't details of
lighting before you today
[Music]
recommendation is
[Music]
right thank you
for that presentation
council
thank you for that
presentation can i ask about the
question
first please and can you put up the
screen
of the um the road that goes from
there
[Music]
we have the actual building a picture of
the big white building
at the entrance to the carpet to tyler's
mother
just beyond that building is a small
junction
that would be effectively closed off and
a new truck should
there's no carriageway on that side of
the road at all so presumably you're
going to take some of the verge or you
to put
suitable for two-way traffic
and two two
is because
um we know that relay um this is
proposed at the moment to be more for
school use because the 181 houses
haven't come forward
yeah so
you've got parents actually
coming on to that that room two-way
tracking
actually you know trying to pass whether
it's getting to tyler's meadow
rpm park out with their cars all walking
back up to the store
and parents walking back down to the car
park to pick their car up and go home
i've actually spoken to a lot of the
parents and they're not proposing to do
that we don't have the time we drop the
children and off they go so it's all
about their needs really i know it's got
permission
but a 50 card working division
in that place and if you're thinking
about the school's going to use it i
think it's going to be a big white agent
along with the lighting and i know
that's that's that's covered but you are
in a dark skies area
tyler's never got their
plan
own
management
own lights on it all and you've got jam
lighters
on the cardboard goodness so what time
have you switched on it up maybe
presumably as far as as long as the
street lights on
that is still going to interrupt in that
size area and become a bit of a nuisance
to local people
um that's why i'm coming on
at the moment and can you tell me that
there's just recently been a
consultation a private scheme
for parents going to the school where
cars aren't allowed
at all and i wonder if you've had any
any feedback on that because
you know if they're not driving down
here at the moment they're not going to
use a car park if that's successful
anyway
um certainly there's
um currently a scheme called the school
street scheme in place where the road is
effectively closed
um at the start and end of the school
day so that people
can't park right next to the school
and then annoy all of the people who
live there and block their driveways
that the feedback from that has been
generally positive
and seems to work well the small school
like it which is the parenting to like
it
unfortunately some of the residents a
bit further away now don't like it
because people park
further away in front of their driveways
and i have spoken to the officer who's
responsible for that this afternoon
and they're looking to make that
permanent that's through public
consultation um
it involves parents or volunteers from
the school going out going up science
closing netting through people we need
to get through because
in this case it is the only trial that
we've got such as steam in the county
where it isn't just a cold attack you
know people do need to go to a patient
um but with uh perhaps being to them
with the new car park in place and the
new road through the new housing state
there is potential for people to go down
through the new road of cargo car park
and avoid the safer uh the school
streets own area so that they wouldn't
be people driving through it still
yet they would then wouldn't be parking
in front of other properties further
away
and annoying those residents so it is an
opportunity
to provide parking in a safe location
where people children couldn't safely
walk to school
we can only ever build something and
hope people use
[Music]
[Music]
plan then that doesn't show
the new role him to turn his meadow does
it no there is
[Music]
picking up uh what comes from brown says
there'll be another junction just sort
of
three junctions in that stretching road
there
yeah
you've got the new one the new access
yeah so is it just north of the green
space there's an existing
road next to the
hatched out
the stem building
then the new entrance
there's a junction through to thailand
and then two car park entrances
but the green the green space triangle
piece is where the soak away is proposed
to be there
let's say the circulation down that area
or
potentially
the car park
or in the long run in the future this is
very unlikely to be built unless the
housing moves ahead i've not seen anyone
that the developer would have to fund it
so i can't say that they would do this
without housing so they couldn't
potentially go into the fields
to the south or elsewhere in that cycle
yeah can i get one thing clear
the applicant is
the company developing the houses but is
devon county insisting on this or is
[Music]
so
when i hear
there's going to be lots of trees and
a wild flower meadow
now when i was talking to prince charles
recently
[Laughter]
we actually talked about wildflower
meadows and he said how much work they
need
to actually
get them going
who's going to pay for the maintenance
of this stock
it's it's not being maintained by
different county council
but who's going to maintain it i mean
somebody's going to have to maintain it
there is a requirement in the section 1
6
agreement for this and the housing site
that management arrangements need those
householders on the newest state who are
going to be paying for it
possibly it could be a part of the
management company or it could come to
either district council or democrats
council subject to legal arena really
first of the torridge could be
responsible um i have to come back with
that because i suspect all of us i'm
getting more and more complaints
from people who bought houses
who are locked into a so-called
maintenance
contract
where the maintenance doesn't exist or
is very shortly done yet they have no
comeback and they keep going up every
year and i'm amazed now you're telling
me that
something that devon county wants
the cost for it is going to fall not in
devon county but either on torridge or
the householders
um
i i just i find that really odd
i mean what what's the benefit to the
householders why should they vote for it
a matter for the previous committee when
the decision was made out of it
i think
as long as i understand it
councilor brown will correct me if i'm
wrong
and it was felt as a requirement for a
car park for the school
it stands from what councilor brown said
that's not likely to be the case that
the school
people dropping
children off at school won't use it and
indeed they may not even
drive down to the school before long to
drop children
it's uh it's a mystery to me why this
scheme is this just this card
has come forward because there's no
guarantee to be built before any housing
in the bill
so i don't know why it's coming
but i suppose the applicant's entitled
to
put part of the section but control
members attention to paid 75 onto
the fourth paragraph up to the bottom
where it says that
in the last sentence furthermore should
a housing development come forward and
it become apparent that the car park is
no longer needed
then there would be a mechanism to amend
section 106
associated with the permission so they
may not even construct it at the end of
the day
even if it gets planned
more houses were going over there
but i i did raise at the virtual site
visit
and it's not just with this
application
it's with lots of reserve matters
applications that come in
let me never get the full details
of conditions that are put into outlines
sometimes they change
in the outline once the outline's
granted
um nominated non-material elements come
in
conditions get applied to be launched
but i do think
schemes that need a drainage scheme with
it
and conditions of how you would secure
this car
i think the public and this committee
the right to know
at reserve mass estate what that will be
and
i take it i accept that helen the
planning officers mentioned
that there's a drainage scheme for it
that would not have the details yet with
a french drain proposed to run around
the outside of it and that the surface
will be
chippings
so
it would be a permeable surface rather
than taliban but it won't know how
what's the permeability of that site
if there's any work being done i don't
know if any work's been done on that
and helen's looking whether she's not
bouncer
sure
sure
sorry
yeah
is it something
it is
paragraph down page 75
uh halfway in the paragraph it says here
uh as in indicated above the principle
of the car park has already been agreed
and whether it is needed or not is not a
matter for the reserve matters stage
uh it is clear however that the car park
is only required to serve the housing
development
you know so
i don't know what we kind of where we're
going with it that's a minute
helen
[Music]
um there's obviously an outline in place
so that principle is established so
reserve matters
as members know it's just those reserve
matters that you're considering today so
the principle of whether it's needed or
not is not for consideration
and i am aware however that there are
local concerns in regards to the car
park whether there is a need for it
particularly in light of the recent
school streets initiative um so i wanted
to make it clear and i have spoken to
some of the local residents about this
as well that
um
you know the outline was considered at
the same time as the initial outline for
housing it was
unfortunately kept as a separate
application at that time i'm sure those
of you who are on commission will
remember
but it's it's clearly only required to
mitigate the housing so so that
terminology that you read probably
wasn't quite right it's not to serve the
housing development they will have all
their own parking to serve individual
drones but it's to mitigate at peak
times
that highway the traffic generation will
come as a result of 381 houses
so
this was also accepted by the appeal
inspecting and allowing the appeal and
specifically referencing it so
the
the matters before you today is whether
those those five matters the reserve
matters are acceptable not whether it's
needed or not if a developer does come
forward at any point in the future to
bring forward the 181 dwellings um
as a planning department would hope that
any developer would engage in
pre-application discussions both with us
and the county council and
the need for the car park can we scope
to revisit that but there would need to
be evidence that it would need um that
section 106 to be buried in the extent
to which that in itself
um is acceptable or what i can't you
know i can't confirm at this point in
time but it would only come forward
as matt collins alluded to no no one is
going to build this because there's no
incentive to build it other than to get
the houses and mitigate that highway
impact
oh really ellen sorry no
sorry
um so really
what we're looking at here even even if
we we agreed to this
that to approve it
uh it's all down to the developer coming
along because it won't get built until
then
if they if if they want to build it
yeah
i i can't say exactly what might happen
if there's a permission in place on a
piece of land it's open to anybody to
acquire that if somebody even terribly
wanted to build a car park they could
because they would be planning
permission however what i would say is
it's highly unlikely that anybody would
come and just build this kayak in
isolation
it is mentioned and acknowledged under
the highway considerations of that
appeal decision the legal agreement
which the inspector considered and
agreed and
specifically has a trigger for the car
park um off the top of my head i can't
remember it's a certain point through
the development when the car park is
needed so
um
you know it it's unlikely that it would
be built until such time as that
specified number of houses is delivered
on the site so we're we're certainly in
some way of that at the moment however
in terms of sort of planning you know
it's a valid application before you
today to be considered under those
matters that are relevant
council christian yeah this is reserve
matters so i think i'm i can bring it up
again
if it does get filled
who owns it because
i get very worried when i suddenly hear
torrents are going to pay for it you
know going to look after the maintenance
um you know are the county's going to do
it is matt gonna pay for it out of his
own pocket you know what what are we
gonna what are we looking at here who
owns it and who looks after it because
car parks as we all know can cost quite
a lot of money to maintain
yeah so um
the the section 106 agreement that's in
place for the housing development
specifically requires
either
it be transferred to the school um
it's it's not it's not guaranteed that
the school would actually want to take
it on and take ownership of it and
maintain it but that is one option the
other option within the section 106
agreement is that the owner and that
would be defined as the developer at
that time sets up a management company
type arrangement for it so the ownership
would either be with the school
or through a management company
type arrangement and this is all
established through
the outline for the housing that's been
approved however the the outline for
this particular development includes a
condition that specifically requires
details of the
house of operation methods of security
maintenance and that would go as far as
the landscaping the world flat meadow as
well so there is a condition on the
outline for the car park that requires
those details in terms of the ownership
of it that is linked with the housing
application because it's clearly
mitigation for that
so if in the future
the company sets up a maintenance
company to look after which i know is
usually
but what happens if that car park
suddenly needs a lot of work because of
the drainage or whatever so they go back
and charge all the households and say oh
by the way you're responsible i mean
this is reserved matters i need to get
this sorted out before i vote for this
i think until such a management
arrangement an ownership arrangement
comes back through the section 106 and
discharging of that obligation and we
know if a developer is coming forward
and who that is in those arrangements i
think we can really i can answer the
detail of that if it's a management
company it depends on the terms under
which that's set up
so it wouldn't necessarily be the
residents paying into that
but that would be something for that for
that stage that's if it doesn't go
across the school
so long as it's not tourist um can i can
i ask you mentioned section 106 is that
in the future
they've got to sign up for this because
you know i keep going about
the local councils need to be involved
in any section 106 discussion
is this a section one or six in the
future or have they already
this is the section 106 i'm referring to
is the legal agreement that the
appellant prepares for the appeal so
um when you go through an appeal process
if an illegal agreement is required
that has to be signed and completed
before the
as it was an inquiry before the inquiry
closes
so it was it was a very it was a
different circumstance it was very much
driven by the appellant so it wasn't we
didn't because the application was
refused by us for the housing we didn't
engage with board members in terms of
section 106 obligations so it was
somewhat
outside of the normal planning
application process and it's already
signed through the appeal process so
that would be dated march 2020.
sorry sorry i don't follow that
because we refused it we didn't enter
into section 106 agreement
so
we went to appeal so the onus was on the
appellant to perfect to prepare a
section 106 agreement of course there
were negotiations with
you know the devon county council in
terms of the car park and
and you know various other parties but
it wasn't considered a planning
application statement
we we had inputs
on the so can i ask through the chair
can i ask councillor brown did you have
input into that no
but surely sorry jeff it it must have
been to do with the inspector yes yes
it's inspected
decision and self-compliance
can uh can i just let sean come into
youtube
i think the chat um
it's very interesting when you're ready
to counsel bristly actually and this is
part of the danger about where that
patient refuses to stay with us appeal
especially at public inquiry
as the question was quite rightly said
while we were refusing an application
there's no need for section 106
agreement um and as we're refusing it we
wouldn't have those negotiations or
discussions with members as we always do
from schedule 106.
the it's free inspector
as the decision maker at that time
to drive that session 106
our process in where we
contact board members and discuss one
state members is an internal protocol
for colleges and council
now when the planning is spectra are
involved
through an inquiry
they're dealing with it on their basis
and there's no need no requirement for
them to then discuss it and in fact it's
done within the days of the public
inquiry
and those of the members of committee i
went up and acquired will understand the
level of detail that the inspector and
that was going on that
so there wouldn't have been any direct
consultation events
you learn something every day thank you
for that clarification sean
yeah um
matt collins
[Music]
did you want to make a comment
[Music]
for one minute the school wanted to take
over a car park
with all the other
stuff they've got to organize and find
it so i cannot imagine it going down
that road but i'm concerned about um the
service of the car park i can't
understand why they're using gravel
when it's really stuck in the
countryside why don't they keep with the
grass
plastic or metal membrane over the top
of it like they're doing lots of car
parts of the countryside
we have what's before us for
consideration um
that approach was was a principle agreed
outline stage i think you have to look
at it in the context that there would be
housing wrapped around it if it came
forward so i think the sensitivity of
that rural location probably wouldn't
necessarily
specify it retained its grasp given you
will have the the access points coming
in but i do agree you know there are
more sensitive options out there that
could be achieved
thank you
yeah i'll propose that we
approve this
because i can't see that
read this any other way because
one
if if if nobody comes forward it won't
get built anyway
so
uh
what the heck
uh so our proprietor
yeah
[Music]
i know you made a valiant attempt
to explain to me it might be not being
bright enough condition 15
um which is to do with how that car park
will be again
and downtown condition
and conditions
this is on the outline position
yeah
condition 13
the drainage which was on
[Music]
without knowing any of that
and that my question is why
we don't insist on planning officer
insist that they before that commission
nothing we know exactly what's proposed
because i think as i keep repeating yeah
the public and ourselves of the right to
know how it will be
you know we're not getting all that in
my view we're not getting all the
information yeah to make a valid
judgment on that card yeah that's my
view
okay so
the
the detail of for example the surface
water drainage that that's clearly
required prior to commencement
this is the standard protocol which is
the condition that we have recommended
from definite floodways and the ea and
it is our approach um in order to
establish the principle of a car park on
the scale closed before you outline
stage the flood risk assessment was
actually very detailed it does details
of the trial picks
the um
the permeability of the site and
a solution is put forward and this
layout is consistent with that and
allows for that and
that risk assessment would have been
considered at the outline stage so there
was reasonable confidence that this
could come forward
and
sometimes we can word conditions and we
do that require details specific details
about the reserve matters stage and
that's something we can certainly look
at where it's something that you do need
often housing developers will also
seek to discharge conditions at the same
time as the reserve matters certainly on
some of our big housing sites that's
quite key with surface water drainage um
so often that information is there
albeit under a condition
rather than the layout as such but at
least i appreciate that's helpful for
members in terms of being able to look
about at the same time
and i would say in this instance um
your office's view is that you can be
you can be confident that
that satisfactory self-esteem
[Music]
can come forward on the basis of what's
before you for consideration everything
is consistent with the flood risk
assessment that was looked at in detail
out on stage
um
if the housing does come forward it's
possible that it would be a more
comprehensive look at the surface water
certainly where the soak away is
proposed with the access road because
there's local ways to serve
the um
the highway works at california so there
could be something else that comes
forward in the future
and you do have the comfort that no
works can start on site until that
condition is discharged and the detail
of that would be we would consult with
the relevant authorities on that as well
if it materializes that
the layout can't come you know come
forward with a satisfactory surface
and provision
then the layout would need to be changed
in which case it would come back through
to committee and i appreciate that's
quite a convoluted way and you could
have had the information up front but i
think you can take conflict from that in
this case but it's something we can
certainly look at moving forward in
terms of the wording of our conditions
my point is in general yeah on the site
the drainage um
whilst it
could be dealt with under a conditioner
outline
with this because this site is so much
higher than turner's metal two and a
half meters two two nothing
the drainage of that site is very
important
you could have flooding occur off the
site i'm not saying it would but this is
like for me would be important that we
knew it at a reserve management before
we grant full planning permission to
that car park we know those details and
again on the security aspect with the
police and crime committee
officers reporting back security gates
on it
and questions have been raised about the
security and writing i think it would be
that how it would operate
i do appreciate that officers can
you know
be the best one in the world
than that we are
you might accept something that this
committee would not accept but the
public
[Music]
[Music]
but i would like full details to be able
to make a proper judgment on it and i
don't believe i've got full details to
make a judgment
particularly on the
drainage of it and the security of it
sure
um just coming back on some of those
points
we have got the outline permission which
has been granted and there are
conditions on that which were agreed by
a committee
um in my advice to members if we were to
seek to recommend using on the basis of
lack of drainage and that would be for
the unreasonable and it's not going to
recommend
members should look down that way
um
clearly we can look at future conditions
um we're looking at our commissions but
in this instance we have got a great
outline permission there are conditions
there relating to maintenance and
training security and that makes it if
there was to be refusal but for
all those matters not having enough
information there nothing out at the end
you mentioned the committee of these
conditions
uh yes i believe the outlying commission
was a committing decision
yeah
okay
[Music]
i will second council watson's motion to
approve right
there's a 30 mile hour
evening
20 miles per hour if it comes forward
and it's approved
it's cool to do that
i don't think that's within the remit of
this planning application
[Music]
recommended to approve this by
councillor watson certainly by
councillor
samuel j
thank you chair council about it four
councillor brown gates council christie
councillor
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um if members giving that proposal
members may wish to use their proposals
[Music]
these two conditions
we need a bit more information
[Music]
if we if we're going to defer it ellen
has to get the information that you
really like yeah let me ask you is that
right
that's my understanding
so surely anyone who wants it rejected
has got to come up with planning reasons
and you've got to go over another vote
to reject it yeah
exactly
we can be fair
thank you
so it's been proposed by myself and
secondly by councilmember to defer this
application for further information
somebody's hit the vote on that page
that's about two
four
all right thanks let's carry them by
five to four to five
you've won the vote to defer it and come
back can i ask can we get some more
precise information on who will own it
and who does the maintenance on
i i get worried when i hear oh torres
might do it you know devon county i'm at
the school
can we get something definite is that
possible
no
oh
well that's been heard councilman
christie so we might have when it comes
back again
but surely you're gonna have to tell her
exactly what she has to do to bring when
for it to come back here
without us going through all this
rigmarole again
with respect it's not written wrong
that's my language but but
probably it's not right for devon but
the thing is i i don't want it to come
back here again and then we start asking
more questions so she has to go away
again
so if we can set that set out what we
need to ask ellen to do
right then that will be fine right we're
moving on anyway now pages eighty and
your agenda application action seven
little brackets d
we've got helen wise in support who's
the applicant who sent a statement
[Music]
and councillor
members
who called the applications
thank you ryan
thank you chairman
um presents an application one slash
zero five seven twenty twenty twenty one
four the application is for a change of
use from an agriculture theory to a dog
exercise field and a question reason
right
the
application side is located to the south
of northern paris at the appleblood
entrance
um it is located northborough's lane and
is accessed by an existing fuel gate
uh this is a view of boris lane towards
northern paris and the entrance you can
see
the sort of field game on the left-hand
side where that white jeep is
and then obviously northern forest in
the sort of background i'm standing at
the sort of nearest residential property
[Music]
and this is the field from north virus
sort of looking back towards the field
and this is zero in front of you and
sort of residential toilets behind
and this is a site plan you can sort of
see
the demarcated sort of fencing
arrangements and gate arrangements so
you've got the parking
on that sort of right hand side and then
on the left that's where they question
and
then the field behind the sort of gate
entrances there
and this is a
detail of the gate
and the detail of the fencing
and these are the main planning
considerations
and
if you have any questions i'll be happy
to answer them
before we've got speakers to come
thank you
my first thing that is
is having wise here
oh sorry you've got to stay with me
again
[Music]
so this is a statement from uh heaven
wise
dear members of the committee
regarding planning application one
slasher 957s
i'm writing to you to address the
concerns being raised by councillor
hayes and we're looking to set up the
secure job exercise field to provide an
immunity for the public to exercise
their dogs where they can let them run
loose saving the knowledge they will not
come into contact with other dogs
livestock wildlife people or disappear
into the distance
since lockdown more people own dogs and
many of these dogs are reactive and
suffer from anxiety around other animals
prior to my affirmation my canvas local
opinion i was overwhelmed by a positive
response
one of the primary comments was that
it'd be local and people could walk
their dogs to and from it
the visual impact will be minimal as a
field would be fenced through
agricultural fencing and i have sourced
wooden gates to the appropriate size
which will blend in better than
galvanized ones
once the fencing is in place i want to
plant wildflower areas to soften the
boundaries and encourage insects and
birds
i'm not looking to develop the field but
asking for change of use to the field
will remain field
i anticipate the majority of people
using the field will only bring a single
dog and even those with more than one
will not necessarily make any more noise
in dogs on the neighboring boroughs
the secure field is not aimed at dog
agility groups where dogs are currently
excitable embarking more
i have spoken to my immediate neighbours
and none of them have expressed any
concern
the fields are hitting the bros lane at
a point where there's room for cars to
pass in both directions
i plan to give ample room for people to
drive straight in off burst lane and
park them turn before joining
so this will not cause any hold up on
the road
the majority of the time is likely to be
single cars arriving and leaving
we all know that not all job owners are
responsible in clean and healthy dogs
but having discussed this with people
that use secure job fields i'm confident
that owners wanting to use it and who
are prepared to pay for the benefits for
adults being able to run free are going
to clean that bad for them
none of them want to take their dog into
a dirty field so it is in their own
interest to pick up out the dog
the field will be inspected regularly
and users will be asked to report any
issues
should any concerns arise as a matter of
owners not cleaning up back their dogs
or any other issues i'm going to store a
cctv camera to monitor the situation and
any owners not complying with the rules
will not be allowed future use on the
field
as a grazier northern boroughs i'm also
acutely aware of the number of incidents
of dogs worrying livestock and have what
is firsthand the damage that can be done
and believe that anything that will help
to achieve these instances is a good
thing for all concerned
i hope this will cover all your
questions and concerns regardless heaven
wise
thank you sean and uh our next speaker
is um
councillor
for a member
um i've called this application in
because of a number of concerns
primarily about immediately and
supervision of the proposed facility
on the meaning it is important to know
that the environmental protection
officers um to note the environmental
protection officer's comments about the
likely adverse effect on neighbouring
residents of dogs barking at the site
he states that although there is
reasonable separation between the
application sites and neighbouring third
party dwellings there is the potential
for disturbance from dog barking which
can be audible over significant distance
particularly in areas of low background
noise such as the locality of the
proposed development
so the officer recognizes that although
there is separation between the site and
neighboring weddings there is still
potential for disturbance from dog
sparkling
having stated this however he
surprisingly decided not to object in
principle to the application
surprising too is that having recognized
the potential noise problem neither the
applicants or the officer providing any
evidence of likely noise levels from
dogs on the site how far the noise will
travel and at what point this will
constitute a nuisance also life proposes
mitigation measures which should help
reduce the impact of dog sparking
the outcome proposes to allow up to four
dogs per person in half hour slots as i
understand it seven days per week 365
days per year that varies the time per
day in accordance with seasons
seven hours in winter eight in spring
autumn and ten in summer
however and again surprisingly your
officers propose four dogs with no
seasonal variation at all which will
potentially cater for up to 80 dogs a
day for
365 days a year
and not inconsiderable number
may i suggest
that in either case but particularly
with no seasonal variation allowing four
dogs at the time could quite easily lead
to a lot of noise when they interact
with each other
the sound of dog sparking can in the
works of the environmental protection
officer the old ball over a significant
distance and i note that the nearest
dwelling to the site is just 50 metres
away while there are other dwellings in
the vicinity of watertown
so on the issue of impact on residential
armenian community i submit the
applications contribute to their
policies dm1a and dm14d and
mdpf 185a
further in support of this concern it's
relevant to say that the site is in the
undeveloped coast the status governed by
policy sto9 which specifies amongst
other factors that the development
should not detract from the tranquility
of the area
please note too that currently the site
is designated for agricultural use
the case offers a case officer asserts
that if a change of use from agriculture
to recreation is allowed the situation
will be no different from what applies
to northern boroughs the entrance to
which is dusted on barrow's lane
however the burroughs is designated as a
country park where all sorts of
recreational activities are committed
including taking dogs for exercise
in contrast the proposed site is a new
site in the undeveloped coast where
policy stone implies with existing uses
for agriculture and which is
significantly nearer than the boroughs
to houses
it is also more likely i suggest
productive four dogs at a time in a
confined space
running off the lead and interacting are
more likely to bargain dogs in wider
spaces of burrows
the measures proposed for supervision
also relate strongly to the immunity
impact in fact in fact i'll stand from
an email sent by the applicant to the
case officer that there will be no
on-site supervision
she states an email that the dog owners
will be given a cone to open the gate
and they will be responsible for
clearing up their mess and for
supervising the dogs on site which i
assume will include prevention of
excessive party
it seems strange to me that there will
be no supervisor on site in short
compliance for these matters and they
also wonder how it would be guaranteed
that goddard
would comply with the number of dogs
allowed that they wouldn't join his
friends to access the site when they had
to code and how would they stop from
exceeding their lot of time
and one to two if everyone will be
dutiful in picking up dog feces
therefore therefore creating a potential
health hazard
regarding the parting application
related to a question grazing please
consider whether the combination of this
and dogs running around barking through
the day into the year would be a benefit
to the horses which should be grazing
next to the site in a relatively small
area
personally i have serious concerns about
welfare the horses and whether
disturbance could lead to frightening
these animals
i'm also concerns about access to the
site the entrance is on our entrance is
on the narrow lane which is a constant
use by visitors driving to the barrows
the lane also takes a fair amount of
pedestrian bike traffic so i submit the
limited visibility of an accessing and
leaving site could be a potential
highways housing especially given a
potential number of cars go to the site
every day
finally while i know the applicant's
wishes to provide a facility which will
reduce the incidence of sheep attack by
dogs in northern boroughs may i point
out that the phones behave responsibly
and followed the rules by controlling
their dogs these attacks wouldn't happen
thank you for listening to me and i hope
you will now give the issues a really
serious consideration
if you are disposed of grant permission
then they
that conditions apply which limit use of
the site to weekdays only which is
restrict hours of operation to 94 in the
winter and nine to six and other months
and which limit usage and slot to one
owner and two dogs at a time however i
do strongly suggest that the question of
effect on resident serenity and the
related history of supervision of the
site are paramount with this application
these issues have not
resolved
been
my view and i suggest that this points
to a decision to refuse permission
thank you
thank you councillor haynes
[Music]
that's the end of the um
speakers to this application
i do know this site very well i'm sure a
lot of you do i go down borrows late
every morning
and it is used
quite frequently
i do see vehicles going in and out of
that gate because a land rover
it's a very large field it's a very
large field
and i do think
as the letter that um
shawn read out from the applicant
that the dogs that you can't let off on
a lead on the barrels
this is ideal for them because it'll be
fenced
and they can't get out of it and jobs do
need to run off a big house
i feel sorry for the dogs in the urban
environment always jumping around
channel lead never get a chance to run
and i think it was an imminent
use for this field
and that's it i'll move approval of it
i was talking about that
and also if i could just say something
we talk about you know
people not picking their dogma
well i actually took my my son
daughter-in-law and grand daughter
with our dogs onto the burrows and i've
never seen so much in my life
and i have told
i have told councillor laws and um
council hudson
about it and they're supposed to be
looking into it you could not walk a
meter
without with looking straight ahead you
have to look down on the floor and that
and i'm not exaggerating the door and i
don't say it's your dog's either
because you don't get onto it but but i
can understand that and
i think this will be a good thing
and i really do thank you
i hope you're not confusing the sheep
dropping with josh
cheers
yeah a couple of questions uh i never
saw page 84 we've got highways it's
pretty much gone there um
because i've actually i've got
um google earth up and i'm looking at it
and i know i know the road i was down
there only a couple of days ago and if
you look at the gate into this
it isn't very good and i'm amazed the
highways say
basically because it's only used by one
person at a time there's no problem
i've never heard that before yeah well
you only one person at the time can use
it anyway but if you look at sorry if
you look at this you see there's big
headshares
and the highways haven't said anything i
find that slightly old
um i think something needs to be added
for that because that road is quite
straight and people zoom down there so
they don't get caught at the bottom
where it's only it's so narrow you've
got to back up again so people zoom down
there in order to get to the gate onto
the boroughs
i don't know oh i know you know
sure you know
i don't believe that for one minute
i didn't say that um the other thing is
the application
changing views from across the field to
dog exercise and a questioning grazing
i've never heard nothing about the
horses today i mean
i know we can't look into the future but
a question grazing then you want you
know
pumps and then you want supervisory
dwelling stuff but there's anything to
be said about the horses or are they
going to go onto the field with the dogs
so what's going to happen
yeah sure
[Music]
um
as i have cultural lands
horses can graze my culture not about
changing use anyway so that's the status
quo um so i think the purpose of that
being that we're changing the use of the
dog exercise area so if you're doing
that you'd lose that religion
potentially to
in future great horses which they can do
at the moment so it's just allowing that
tension to carry on
can i ask about the access as well can
we put that as a condition because i
know it's highways haven't flagged it up
but anyone who goes down there you must
realize it's quite dangerous actually
yeah cancer
um
so i should probably confirm at this
point and it does say in the report but
don't count council as they sometimes
too responding with standing advice
towards this application so i've
considered the highways merits of the
application
i consider that the speeds
as i know the site um as you do as well
the speeds along that road are very low
anyway because of the nature of that
road
the difference or the humidity
difference between someone operating and
accessing that land by themselves
one car and the replacement in which
case would be again one car visiting
with their dogs
at
booked um appointments only
is considered to be a negligible impact
to my view
me just come back on that because again
i'm looking at this and if you drive up
to the gate you haven't got enough room
your car will stick out onto the road
you have to get out and unlock the gate
and go is there going to be are they
going to put the gate back or what well
you can see here you've got sort of the
parking aspect here the site shows where
the parking to be located
i don't know if that helps you at all
it's not the path
you talk about the exit yes um
i've i've got what you've got in front
of you here
there is i
yeah there is a bit of a lay delay by a
rough lay-by but people park
where that gateway is so there's still
room for traffic to go past
is sorry it's not so much that it's
you're going to have to unlock this gate
to get in
and
there isn't i'm looking at this right in
front of me there isn't enough room
there to have your car parked in order
to do it
parallel to the road if you're sticking
out in order to go in the gate it's
going to stick out into the road yeah i
appreciate that
my consideration is that obviously
we take regards to the mppf and test
within that about severity and impact on
highways and in
in consideration of that
and speeds which are low within that
road because of the kind of narrow
nature of that road
as people enter and exit from northern
boroughs
i do not think that they would exceed
that impact
okay not my experience but anyway
[Music]
yeah thanks very much to i think the
officers are just touching a few points
there um i wouldn't like to see
the entrance wider because should be
losing headroom to do that but to maybe
put condition on to set it back probably
eight foot
length of a car length of the car then
set the gateway back in which is more
reliable to do i think that would then
immediately
we're trying to do our bit and try to
keep that wave
understand advice by devon county but
it's going to come to us in the end
anyway
so i just think to say conditions but
i'll just sit back for the depth of
account i mean you know did you use that
gateway
and as
ryan said you've got to put me time to
go in there it's not there's a track's
going in there all the time i just
wonder how much use this deal will
actually have i don't think it'll be
overwhelming jobs at all i'm sure it
won't be
but um
i mean
i just don't want to you know
put an unnecessary risk
restriction on
because it's just just for me a
straightforward
thing to approve but cancer knows yeah i
mean i was quite confused about the car
parking really because um
in the design and access statement it
states that the market will increase to
two to five spaces
and yet highways comment is based on one
user at the time
but condition number four states that no
more no more than four dogs should be
present at any one time well that could
represent four cows
yeah so the whole thing is a bit
no but
thank you thank you
we've had that information confirmed to
us by the action
um that
it is on a one person per basis one one
card so there are only one car in the
field
and they could have one or four
[Music]
yeah and also picking up on cancer
hayden's is about the hours of
usually it's conditioned at three there
from nine in the morning to 1900 hours
well i don't think in the winter months
people have been there in the dark at
all
so
the question okay
[Music]
um
to put any other conditions on to be
friends
yeah um
did you do you want to make that
condition
you know i would like making a condition
i think
at the road sea breeze i think that's
got a set back
entrance there and that works again to
me i don't see that section of the road
be any different to this section right
that's that's my own opinion i know this
people should do it different but i
would like to see that as a condition
and just leaves everyone's concerns but
we're not against this at all it's just
we're trying to do our best for any
public user pedestrian cyclist or more
vehicle traffic coming in with a lot of
visitors coming to the area
we might we need to be mindful of that
was we know to drive the road but visits
coming in they're not there to do so so
anything to take away potential
be good
our second councilman got a suggestion
all right so it's been proposed
well i'll accept that alexis
just to confirm so we'll be looking at a
further condition uh prior to first use
the access gateway is
set back by
three meters to allow for a good sized
car
um now would members wish for officers
to seek plans of this before we use or
just that condition to allow that
extremely setback
chair
that's not enough
i've seen council watson's car that's 20
football
sure
and if that wording of that kind of
position
dedicated to officers with the chairs
[Music]
[Music]
that there's a three metre setback of
that game
off the lane right
i don't want that searching for opposed
to uh
[Music]
[Music]
what
our final application this afternoon
is application 17.
it's coming to us because it's district
council on property
and angela's
is
property application reference one slash
zero
nine point four uh 2021.
uh the application is for the
replacement of uh first floor
glazing to the
[Music]
before you just indicate the location
[Music]
please
those elevation plans show the
eastern elevation
and the southern elevation with the
circles indicating the proposed
insertion of the new window
and the proposed replacement crazing
just to make members aware that plans
have been amended
subsequently to the preparation of this
presentation as the elevations were
annotated incorrectly
it shows the proposed position
uh of the windows uh with the red arrows
indicating
the new first floor window in southern
elevation the left-hand side and the
existing glazing
on the first floor eastern elevation
which is already there which is supposed
to be the case
following material considerations are
the principle development the character
in appearance
impacts information
ecology and flood risks
if you have any questions
i'm happy to answer hashtags no
questions thank you angelo i notice that
this applicant has a long long relevant
history
[Music]
yeah i've been in to look at it actually
and it will be a good job um no problem
counselor walks and sent me to our
counselor
that this is granted
can you say the vote please number
yes check cancer
or
[Music]
[Music]
thank you everybody we are
now tomorrow
[Music]